and as always our recordings of our
virtual meetups will be available on
YouTube about a week after the Meetup uh
we'll post the message on the Meetup
when the recording is ready
so I'm very pleased to introduce our
speaker today Rainer dronzek
sorry
uh Raynor is a fellow solution architect
in the simulation and decision science
practice at engineering USA a provider
of digital transformation Technology
Solutions and services headquartered in
Chicago he has held Technical and
Leadership positions in the Aerospace
oil and gas software and Consulting
Industries he was first introduced to
simulation modeling on the space shuttle
program at the Kennedy Space Center and
has been involved ever since his
simulation Project work covers a wide
range of Industries using many different
simulation applications
he has managed simulation projects and
standing teams providing modeling
Services founded an independent
simulation consulting firm collaborated
with universities and professional
societies and organized simulation
modeling events and conferences
and then for questions feel free to put
them in the chat and then you can also
use the Razer hand feature and then
Rainer will get to your question or I'll
like also indicate there's a question
okay so now I'm very happy to pass it
off to Rainer and yeah Rainer you can
take it away
thanks Olivia
um and uh absolutely feel free to chime
in with questions uh we have a small
enough group where
um I think we can make this very
Interactive
um so thanks for uh spending your
evening with me or your happy hour
and my talk today is going to focus on
on simulation modeling and I know you've
had a couple talks within the past few
years I know one of the folks from
manylogic talked about AI integration
with a tool called any logic and dove
into the code
um my intent is to give you a little bit
higher level view but we'll also kind of
peek under the hood as I mentioned in uh
in the abstract so peppered throughout
the presentation I will show you
simulation model demonstrations from a
couple different applications
but I want to kind of talk about kind of
an introduction to simulation modeling
um will
talk about a couple of key terminology
points that are buzzwords that are very
common in the industry and and in some
cases may cause some confusion so I just
want to level set on what I mean and
what we mean in the simulation modeling
World by a digital twin in Industry 4.0
uh we'll talk about a little bit the art
versus the science of of simulation
model I'll give you a list of all the
software packages or most of the
software packages that are out there
both commercially available and open
source and then talk about a couple
things that are relatively new in the
industry uh one is hybrid modeling and
the second is integration with
artificial intelligence
so let's get started the first is to
make sure that we're all talking the
same language because uh simulation
and model are both very generic terms
that can cover lots of different things
and so uh sometimes when I talk with
folks about simulators they think of uh
you know Battlefield tank simulators
Healthcare simulators
um aircraft simulators and things like
that that's not what we're going to be
talking about today
and if we talk about models there's lots
of different types of models ranging
from mental models to Excel spreadsheets
to formulas one of the common ones that
and I want to say causes some confusion
but it is a differentiator within our
industry would be physics-based models
where we're doing things like
computational fluid dynamics actually
modeling the physics of something that's
not what we're going to be talking about
here either our Focus will be on kind of
process based simulation models
so I'm going to start and actually just
jump into a simulation
and I'm going to start with and use in a
couple
different ways a distribution center
simulation model
and my computer is slowing down so
hopefully this will work good so this
happens to be a tool called any logic
I'm going to use two different tools
today during the talk I'll also talk
show you a list of of all the other ones
that are out there
um
and just want to confirm uh can you
still see my screen because mine
is looking different
okay got it I see Olivia nodding thank
you so this is the development
environment for uh a tool called any
logic all the tools that are basically
out there are what I call general
purpose simulation modeling tools so
they're intended to allow you to model
virtually anything some of them have
specialized industries that they're best
for but in in most cases they can be
applied to virtually any process a lot
of times the distinction is the the
graphics that come with the package that
make it a little more easier to
communicate a particular topic within a
particular industry but in general their
their general purpose simulation
modeling tools
so I'm gonna
um I'm just gonna run this model
and then we'll walk through what you're
seeing
so the splash screen is here and you can
you can see this particular tool one of
the interesting things is it gives you
gives you the ability to design in
interaction with the actual animation so
I could pre-select certain parameters
for this particular model as I enter in
this um in this splash screen and I'm
going to press the Run button and what
you'll see is the model appear in a new
screen
and res and you can see that there's
movement so
many times people confuse this with oh
it's a it's a animation program true it
does give you the ability to animate
but more importantly there are
statistics and details and process
underneath here that are the real value
with with these type of tools
so just by way of kind of orientation
what you're seeing is a simplistic
Distribution Center where I have on the
right hand side I have trucks coming in
they're unloading pallets
the pellets are are moved to storage
locations by forklifts
and then so that's the inbound the
outbound you can see the trucks that are
picking up from the loading dock so the
forklifts are assembling uh orders that
are then moved into the truck and so
what this model is intended to look at
is kind of the schedules of the trucks
that are coming in the number of
forklifts that I have how long it takes
to pick things from the rack going into
an assembly area and then the outbound
schedule for the truck so every
simulation project has some type of
objective around which the model is
built and it's intended to answer
certain questions that you might have
and so that'll be one of the things that
we talk about later on successful
projects is making sure that you're very
clear on what the objective for the
project is so that you can build the
model appropriately
you can see this is uh most applications
these days give you the ability to do
both 2D and 3D obviously 3D is a lot
more pleasing
and call it eye candy it does nothing
for the accuracy
um of the simulation it's more for
helping with the storytelling
and I can kind of zoom in on a couple
particular areas
and again you can see with this
particular
tool as well as this particular model I
have the ability to change parameters so
I could change the number of forklifts I
could change some of the type times it
takes to do things I could change
capacities
so in this case this type of a model
often what somebody's looking at would
be if this is a new process how many
forklifts do I need to buy
how many forklifts and and forklift
drivers do I need to be able to support
this operation
what happens if my volume increases next
month if I double my volume where will
the bottleneck be and where will the
bottle neck move to that's uh probably
one of the keys you know so typically
simulation modeling comes out of the
industrial engineering discipline in
schools that's typically where it's
taught sometimes in operations research
as well and and I would argue that if
there's an Industrial Engineer at this
facility they know where the bottleneck
is it's pretty simple to walk out on the
floor and see where it is the question
is if you make a change to the process
where does the bottleneck move to and
that can get complex to predict and
that's one of the benefits of simulation
modeling
so in addition to the visualization
I'm also interested in what the
statistics are so I'm going to speed
this model up a little bit just to kind
of generate some of this uh statistics
and these are kind of a a couple of the
traditional and common things that I
might look at so how long does it take
to do things so what's the processing
time within each of these steps in the
process so unloading
um assembling an order picking a pallet
from a storage location those type of
things and utilization is an indication
of how busy is something it could be a
person it could be a forklift it could
be a space virtually any parameter that
I Define that has kind of a fixed
capacity or is some type of a constraint
on the system I'm going to look at the
utilization so you can see my forklifts
are pretty pretty well utilized right
now so I don't have a lot of wiggle room
and more than likely if I added more
forklifts it's quite possible that my
processing time would be reduced because
I'm at 100 utilization so I'm using most
of the forklifts that I have
the loading docks they're at about 60
utilization so there's still more space
there so that might be one of the things
that I might want to look at is if I'm
trying to optimize my process
and in addition to kind of the 2D and 3D
look of things I can also customize the
way I want to present information so
this is more of an abstract view that's
showing the kind of the key process
steps and how many things are in each of
those steps so you can see I have a lot
of things in queue right now
um and this appears to be one of the
areas that I might want to focus on
which would be to try and reduce this
cue and balance these cues out the the
amount of objects that are being
processed throughout the system so I can
create these custom
animations and and Abstract
representations of systems or process
rather than just relying on you know a
cad based or a very detailed process
look
um and then I have the ability to kind
of move in and out
um and and have camera views and camera
angles and and hone in on particular
things
so that's an example of a of a
simulation model uh again this one
happens to be any logic
and it's a distribution center
typically what you'll see the use for
this would be uh from the the folks that
are managing the Distribution Center so
if I have a question if I'm going to
insert new automation I might build a
simulation to help justify or understand
if that actually is the true bottleneck
because if I'm going to spend a million
dollars on an automated storage and
retrieval system I want to make sure
that I'm spending that money wisely that
that actually is the bottleneck and that
I'm accounting for what
performance Improvement I'm going to see
if I install that so I can build a
simulation of the facility and do it
that way oftentimes the on the other
side we also have vendors that are
proposing or building these systems for
a client they will use the simulation
model to identify how well their system
works and sometimes a client will
require a simulation especially in in
Material Handling type systems and and
production systems like you know
manufacturing lines
um Olivia gave you my background
um just a couple of things uh this this
dates me so I go back to the days of
Punch Cards and paper tape readers uh uh
so just to give you a an idea of my of
my vintage
um and as Olivia mentioned I I was first
introduced I worked on a space shuttle
program at the Kennedy Space Center and
we had an I.T group that had lots of
money and they were the first people
within our company that got a hold of
simulation modeling tools and actually
did some some models of the the
processing of payloads for the space
station and so that's where I first
learned about it and then a couple years
later got into it
um
you know and actually within the uh the
Aerospace industry doing some modeling
for uh lean manufacturing operations on
The Joint Strike Fighter
and then consulted in a lot of different
Industries
um uh doing manufacturing projects
um kind of a lot of different areas and
for five years I led the operations
research group at the McDonald's
Innovation Center we did things other
than simulation modeling but we did use
simulation to help understand the
operations in the restaurants as well as
the flow of customers and staff and
vehicles and things like that so it was
a pretty powerful tool for helping to
improve operations there and these days
I'm working for a company called
engineering USA we're a consulting firm
working on a lot of different projects
mainly manufacturing oriented so for
example a big one right now looking at
the operations around the maintenance
and support of Navy fleets activities
engineering USA basically we're a
consulting firm focused on the digital
transformation we're going to talk a
little bit about this later uh when we
talk about industry 4.0 but the whole
idea is moving from paper and from
disparate software systems that might be
across an organization in the life cycle
of a product from design through the
through the delivery of the customer and
trying to get that single digital thread
where we're sharing information and
making the best use of digital
information throughout the entire life
cycle of that product
so again just a level Set uh this is my
definition of of simulation modeling and
most practitioners will probably agree
with most of this
um so it's creating a computer-based
dynamic digital representation of a
business system or process and then
conducting experiments uh using this
digital representation to help you
analyze and predict performance
and it's an executable model that we're
building
So within the simulation package I have
the ability to kind of to Define rules
uh what happens in the process so if you
think about it start with the process
flow and then what are all the decisions
that need to be made through that
process those would be built into the
simulation model
we're moving through time that's one of
the
characteristics of a simulation model
versus other techniques is we can
actually move the simulation Through
Time
um and then we're able to also look at
outputs as the simulation is running and
observe them visually as well
so basically I build a model I have a
series of inputs that I use to drive
that model I run the model and then I
observe both electronically and Visually
the things that are that trajectory is
as the model proceeds and things change
over time and then I can re rerun the
model change the input see was see what
happens and then compare the results to
understand is something better or worse
when I when I change an input
and it's Dynamic this is one of the big
differentiators between this analysis
technique and other other analysis
techniques as well again through time uh
changing conditions over time are
accounted for in variation in the
processes accounted for
so uh our company is headquartered in
Chicago I happen to be in the Madison
Wisconsin area uh kind of been
associated with UW Madison and so I
always have to advertise uh UW Madison
through this quote
uh all models are wrong uh and they are
we have to recognize that but some are
useful and we have to keep in mind the
the the context of the model as we're
putting things together and this leads
in a little bit later when we're going
to talk about the Art and Science of
simulation modeling
so why would I use a simulation model
well if I think about it if I have a
problem to solve and it can be in
virtually any industry I could actually
you know create a mock-up or
Implement something and see what happens
which potentially could be could be even
catastrophic
um and so I'd like to be able to test
what I'm trying to do offline and so I
moved from the real world into the
digital world the world of models I
create a model of my system and then I
test the solutions that I propose to
implement on this computerized version
and only then do I move that solution
into the real world so now I have a
little bit of an insurance policy that
what I've proposed will actually help
and won't harm
so simulation goes back to uh to queuing
Theory uh in in many cases and so just
as a um uh
to highlight one of the benefits of
simulation modeling where we're taking
variation into account we'll just start
with the simple bank teller problem
where
um although these days become it's
becoming less and less common but I walk
into a bank I walk up to a teller I do
something I make a deposit I get some
cash I do some other transaction and
then I leave so very simplistic queuing
Theory problem
and I'm going to keep it simple and say
okay I'm going to build a model of this
and I'm going to define the number of
tellers that are there how long it takes
to do a transaction and how often
customers are coming into the system
and what I'm going to look at is how
long does the customer spend in the bank
how many customers are in queue and
what's the utilization or how busy is
that teller
and in this particular case I'm just
going to make it really simple I'm going
to assume one one teller the transaction
time for every customer is that is
exactly five minutes and the customers
arrive exactly every five minutes as
well so if I look at the results of that
simulation if I build a model of course
you can predict what that's going to be
my transaction time is five minutes the
amount of time that the customer spends
in the bank and and I'm making an
assumption here I'm not including
walking time and things like that so uh
would be five minutes because every
transaction is the same amount of time
there's never a cue because I never have
to build up a cube because there's
always
time available for that teller to to
serve somebody so I never have a cue and
that teller utilization is 100 they're
always busy
so what happens if I start accounting
for variation in the process so rather
than a transaction time of five minutes
I'm going to keep the average of five
minutes but it's actually going to be
somewhere equally likely between four
and six minutes
so that's a uniform distribution
so you can see now I'm going to start to
see some build up I'm going to see Q
times increasing
um uh I should say the number of people
in queue my teller utilization has
dropped a little bit and you can see
that the average time now goes from 5 up
to seven four minutes and the worst case
is one of my customers spent 11.4
minutes so now I'm starting to see the
impact of that of that variation and
kind of the application of queuing
theory now if I move to a transaction
time of one to nine minutes again this
is a uniform distribution
um I can see the situation gets worse uh
teller utilization is not too bad
um and of course I have some customers
that get through the line very quickly
be you know down to 1.2 minutes but the
worst case is one of my customers spent
30.4 minutes and this is because of the
build up of that variation in the build
up of cues the dynamic changing of those
cues over time
and so that's kind of the key that I
might look for here is is I'm looking at
this system you know what do I do well
let me add some mute add some more
tellers and see what happens there so my
teller utilization is going to drop if I
would add a next teller but now I can
look at it from the customer's
perspective and say yeah I can get
through the system quicker
but the reality is
um that was a horribly simplistic model
if you've been to a bank you know that
you could have a ton of other variables
that I need to take into account if I'm
in charge of this process so obviously
customers don't arrive every five
minutes uh on the like uh on like on a
metronome they have some type of a rival
pattern
um
for example when I was at McDonald's we
even looked at things like uh if the
restaurant happened to be at an
intersection where there was an arrow a
left turn arrow so rather than a steady
arrival of cars in the drive-through now
you have bursts of cars coming in and if
you account for the the total experience
time when somebody gets in line that
becomes a big factor in how I'm
trying to look at the process
performance so you can see each step of
the process we can have a lot of
different things from behaviors like
customers jumping between cues if I have
multiple cues how do I account for that
not only do I have tellers but I have
ATM machines I have multitasking I have
priorities I have differences in skill
do I account for breaks so I can easily
build a really detailed model to
represent what is actually happening
within the system
so let me show you uh this is a
different tool this is a tool from
Siemens it's uh Siemens technomatics uh
tool called plant simulation
it's been around quite a quite a while
and it's mainly focused on manufacturing
manufacturing operations and it's also
part of a suite of tools as I mentioned
this digital thread that carries us all
the way from the design all the way to
delivery the customer this is one of
those tools that helps with that oops
and I just missed that there so here's
an example of
um a dairy operation so one of the
things you're going to see is actual the
development environment where I'm
dragging and dropping objects and this
is typically how you're going to build a
model you will drag and drop objects and
then open up the dialog boxes within set
certain parameters and then also write
code AS required for example with
complex decision rules and you can see
this is a little bit more High Fidelity
animation which may or may not be
accounted for depending on what the end
use for the model is
um and and you can see it's it's moving
through some of the uh the the
predefined types of data and here's some
examples on actually going into those
dialog boxes and changing shift
operations for example to see what the
impact on the process is if I add or
reduce hours in my shift
in this particular process uh the the
previous kind of the teller operation
and the warehouse operation was a
discrete operation so things moving
through in chunks of time this is a
continuous operation that you might see
in oil and gas food manufacturing some
areas where I have a constant and
continuous flow of things going through
pipes for example that I can model as
well
so when I do a simulation project uh
ideally what you do is you go through a
pretty structured process just like you
would do for coding or or any other
development activity and the first thing
you do is you document you understand
what the objective of the project is
because then that will help you design
the proper simulation model you
understand understand the scope so when
do I start and when do I stop how do I
bound the process that I'm trying to
model and typically what we'll do is
it's called different things in
different companies but some type of a
simulation design specification that's a
living document it starts up front in
the early phases of the process to say
yes these are all the things we agree to
and as the model matures so does the
simulation design specification just to
make sure that we have a an
understanding and agreement of what the
simulation model is is doing
uh then after I understand and design
then I'm going to build the simulation
model
I'm going to build the user interface
and the preprocessors that allow me to
get data into the model and then the
dashboards and other things including
post processors maybe where I'm going to
understand the outputs of the model and
those are going to be the those kpis
that are that I've identified up front
when I talk about what the objectives
are
then I'm going to verify and validate
the model this is one of the most
critical steps verification means as I'm
sure everybody in this call is is aware
within their own world would be making
sure I've coded the model correctly so
are there errors in the model am I am I
do I have problems between the model and
what was actually designed so that's
kind of the coding process but then I'm
also going to validate after I'm making
sure that the model is structured
correctly now I just have to make sure
that it accurately represents the system
because it's possible when I've designed
the model I haven't accounted for
something that that
results in the model not being a good
representation of what's really
happening and that's really important
because if the people that are using the
model don't believe that the baseline or
that it's that it's accurately
representing what's happening now when I
start making changes to the model and
getting these results sometimes often
very counter-intuitive it's the
believability will be very difficult to
follow and so it's very important that
we verify and then validate the model
and then we start using for analysis
so as we talked about before I can run
the model then it runs through time and
then I get things like output results I
have visualizations to to help
understand the system I can start doing
what-if experiments so let me change
some parameters and see what happens I
can compare those scenarios and see yes
a is better than b or or not for
whatever it is and I talked earlier
about an insurance policy so I can
actually start looking at risk what's
the risk of doing something and I can
use this to help quantify what that risk
might be if I'm going to to apply
something and that's where that process
variation comes in you can see that box
plot is indebted to show that when I run
a simulation model what I'm going to get
out is a range of values with a likely
value and that's where I need to
understand kind of the statistics behind
the simulation as well and then lastly I
can start optimizing so not only am I
going to kind of manually change the
dials and see what happens but now I can
actually use some tools to say let me
hone in on the best solution what's the
right number of forklifts to have let me
optimize the number of forklifts based
on some parameters that I set that I'm
trying to optimize toward that objective
function
so just some examples of you know why I
would want to simulate one of the key
ones is
these models very quickly they come they
become complex very quickly that's
because the systems that we're modeling
are complex and so kind of a spreadsheet
approach is often not good enough to be
able to understand not only complex
interactions but also adaptive systems
so systems that are Dynamic and change
over time based on the conditions that
they're experiencing so that's one of
the ideal uses for for simulation
I can use the model to test things that
would be impossible so for example gosh
just during the recent covid outbreaks
some of the things that people are
looking at would be
um you know if I need to do a mass a
large quantity of of vaccinations uh
it'd be kind of difficult to set up a
trial to see how that works I can use
this offline simulation design uh the
best way to vaccinate a very large
number of people through
um you know vehicles moving into a large
facility I know that's the what we had
here locally and so using that
simulation to test things that you
wouldn't be able to do you know shooter
situations large volumes of things
catastrophic events all things that are
easily tested within a simulation model
where it might be more difficult to do
in a real system
so you can see some of the um some of
the examples here
um on some of the things
that would be advantages for why you
would use a simulation model
so we've all seen these these uh kind of
multiple categories uh three or four
categories of types of data analytics so
the nice thing about simulation modeling
is that it applies to all of them so
descriptive describing what has happened
I can build a model of a system and then
I can help people understand it could be
used for training it could be used to
visualize something that might be
difficult to visualize in a real system
so simulation can be used for
descriptive Analytics
I can just I can use it for Diagnostic
analytics so why did something happen I
can kind of peel the onion within my
simulation and say yes I had a backup
because my teller was 100 busy and so
that's why the queue was building I'd be
able to diagnose that then I can predict
what happens if I change the system
where does the bottleneck move to if I
change some of the process parameters
and then lastly kind of prescriptive not
only what will happen but what's the
best action I should be taking and that
would be using those optimization
techniques to hone in on the optimal
solution based on profit on time
whatever is important in the objective
of the simulation
so here's a little bit of a different
example I'm going to show you a supply
chain
and in this case I'm it's very very
simplistic but I think it kind of
illustrates a couple of cool features
that you might use a simulation for so
this is a
[Music]
um
so I'm gonna do this because my
something's blocking
what I have is is three manufacturing
sites Chicago Pittsburgh and Nashville
serving a series of distribution sites
and what these factories are they're
producing they're being transported
through a truck Network and the cool
thing is I'm actually using a GIS Road
Network as part of this simulation model
so these trucks are following the road
Network to get from point A to point B
so some of the things that I might be
looking at would be you know what's the
production rate for each of these here
the fleet utilization so this is how
busy are the trucks
um and so I might if I'm the
transportation manager I want my might
want to optimize the usage of my fleet
and then the wait time so how long are
Distributors waiting for their product
to arrive and so you can see just as a
as a quick Glimpse uh my Pittsburgh
Fleet is 100 utilized so this is an area
that I might want to look at because I
might be having some capacity
constraints so as I showed you before
one of the things that I could do is I
could in this case I have sliders on
here so I'm going to move this down just
a hair you can see I'm at a hundred
percent if I go back to the animation
and I now increase the number of of
trucks that I have in Pittsburgh
voila I should see my
um
my fleet utilization be reduced and
you'll also notice that my weight for
products is also being addressed so the
fleet size in Pittsburgh was a
bottleneck for my system and by
increasing the number of vehicles I was
now able to kind of even out that that
utilization rate and also improve the
kind of the customer satisfaction and
the delivery times for the customer so
just a quick example of how I might use
the simulation for analysis in a supply
chain and then also integrate with a GIS
system
oh Reena we have a question yes
how do we incorporate the speed limit of
the roads and let the trucks follow the
speeds of the road so this particular
model is
um uh is following the road networks and
what we're doing is we're limiting the
speed of each individual truck for this
particular simplistic model to some
speed limit what we would do is change
the model to move more towards like a A
Google a Google map or a Yahoo map
whatever you use a TomTom to get from
point a point B if the gis system
supports that then I could do that as
well so now that the truck is going to
have some maximum speed but it'll also
decrease and follow the speed limit for
example and I could build all kinds of
decision rules in there
as long as I had the data available in
the gis Network to be able to do that
foreign
cool
um so uh who can tell me what the most
popular modeling tool is
or guess
any guesses
oh wait wait
foreign
so
um and which is not a bad thing uh so
from a Consulting perspective when we
come in and somebody has
realized that they've reached the limit
of what they can do and um and have a
lot of information in Excel
it is an advantage because that means
they have they've got to start on the
data that we need to drive the model
um and so yeah oftentimes you'll see
people using Excel for analyzing a
process and modeling that process
um
and actually I want to make sure because
my
yep uh let me give in a second I'll give
you a list of simulation tools but I
wanted there's three paradigms on how
you develop models um and there's tools
that uh that are focused on each of
those the first is System Dynamics been
around a long time Jay Forrester started
it back in the 50s and it's looking at
the kind of relationship between systems
um and the flow of things it could be
people it could be ideas it could be
information it could be products
whatever it might be and they're they're
modeled at a aggregated level they're
not modeled individually and I have
these feedback loops that are that are
driving the system Behavior
the second is a discrete event
simulation very process focused the
warehouse model that I showed you is an
example of that
and agent-based is uh is probably the
the newer and um what it's looking at is
uh agents moving through a system and
interacting
um between themselves and with the
environment so a little bit of different
approach to uh to how you build a model
in each of these paradigms has kind of
the visual language most tools these
days have some type of of uh uh
graphical user interface that you use to
to build the model so with System
Dynamics we're using the stock and flow
diagrams so it's showing the movement
it's showing feedback loops and kind of
parameters and values embedded within
within each of those discrete event is
very uh process flowchart based so I'm
going to drag and drop process blocks
and then Define the parameters for each
of those and then uh agent based
where I use State charts which are a
fantastic way to model and we'll talk a
little bit later about Hybrid models and
I can also use action charts kind of
like decision trees for those as well
and then typically most of the
simulation tools will have a really easy
to use drag and drop interface and then
when you need to get a little bit more
complex there'll be some type of a
scripting language
so any logic uses Java
and plant Sim the other tool that I
showed you uses a language proprietary
language called simtalk and virtually
every simulation tool has some type of a
language that they use where you're
actually going to be writing code when
the the easy way of you know radio
buttons or selecting things and using
pull Downs needs to be taken a step
further
here's a list of uh kind of the
the main simulation tools that you'll
see out there that are commercially
available
I mentioned um I've been showing you any
logic
um and uh plant Sim
but there's lots of others out there as
well
there's also open source simulation
tools
um probably the most common we're gonna
I'll show you an example would be Senpai
which is a set of libraries for python
to build models but these are some of
the other tools that are out there open
source typically out of universities or
government institutions uh so sets of
libraries to build models like netlogo
and swarm and repast our agent-based
modeling tools
so I won't go into the details one
because I can't I'm not a programmer but
I'm dangerous enough to point people in
the right direction so there's a link
here that will get you to one example of
using Senpai but basically you can see
here's the code that's used and here is
just they actually developed a a
visualization of a process as well so
you can see things moving through a
process getting in queue spending time
and then also separately having the
ability to kind of output the results of
the simulation as well so you know it's
a really good free open source way to uh
to build a queuing theory model using
python
I did that already
so one of the things you're going to
hear uh maybe you've heard a lot about
is this idea of a digital twin and the
idea is to have a digital representation
of an actual system that I can use to do
a lot of different things so I can
monitor it I can do what-if scenarios I
can help improve performance
and it's this digital copy that I can I
can visualize the real system I can
interact with the digital version of it
and I can experiment and again kind of
in this risk-free environment offline
environment before I make any changes to
the real system
and there's three typically uh three
pillars around digital uh digital twins
the first is uh between the model and
the actual system you have to have some
level of of connectivity two-way so not
only is the model kind of looking at the
system but the system is providing
information on its state back to the
model and typically that's through iot
devices so Internet of Things devices
connected uh sensors for example that
are streaming data back to the
simulation
I have a digital copy so obviously you
know we were building these computerized
models and I have to have some level
intelligence to be able to understand
what's going on what's driving the
system and then what are the sensors
telling me uh back again so that's where
I build the rules into the into the
model itself
so this is generic digital twin and
we're going to talk about and the other
important thing is that it's real time
or near real time so I need to be able
to sync up my model to what's actually
happening to say yes they're exactly the
same now so I've got the latest
information
when we talk about simulation-based
digital twins
um arguably we've been doing simulation
for a long time and no one called it a
digital twin
because it wasn't a digital Trend
because typically we didn't have it
connected to a live system
so these days I can have a simulation
model that's a digital twin if I do have
that connectivity but not necessarily
every simulation is a digital twin
so the essential characteristics are I
need to have representation a simulation
model of an actual operational system
could be a warehouse it could be a
machine it could be a process and I need
to synchronize the model to the real
system so I press run and I go and I
suck data from the real system it's okay
this is these are the cues right now
this is all the information that's there
these are the machines that are up these
are the machines that are down these are
the number of packages in my warehouse
whatever it might be
um then I can start using the simulation
to make decisions and possibly control
the system as well so we've got to have
that uh connectivity between the two the
model needs to be flexible enough to be
able to change parameters on the fly as
I do my what-if analysis and probably
the most important and this is why we
probably didn't do a lot of digital
twinning in the past is I need to have
that high speed connectivity between the
real simul between the simulation and
the the real
um uh the real system and so you've got
to have that speed and not only speed of
the connection but also speed of the
simulation speed of the iot devices that
we can quickly do that what-if analysis
in near real time
we have uh one more question Chad
uh emulation versus digital twin
um great question and I'm gonna I'm
gonna show you an emulation and I
realize I'm running a little bit long
here but um uh I will I'm going to show
you uh the difference
um so a digital twin will always be some
level of abstraction
um and I'm going to bypass this example
and uh an emulation is going to get
closer to the real system than probably
a digital twin or simulation model will
be because that's when we get into the
the Art and Science of simulation is
understanding what that abstraction
level is
um just real briefly just a reminder of
what industry 4.0 is so here's a list of
uh the industrial revolutions the four
uh and currently we're at what's often
called kind of the iot level so this is
the digital
um representation of things and using
that digital representation to link the
physical world to the virtual world
and I'm going to skip by
uh no I won't I'm going to do this real
quick
um so if we think about the physical
world I've got people assets and
products
and the digital worlds I'm going to be
designing things I'm going to be
producing those things and I'm going to
give them to someone that they're going
to experience the thing as as they're
using it could be a product could be a
phone that I'm going to design
and what I'd like to do is have this
digital thread through all of these
right now often we have disparate
systems or no systems between each of
these element of the product life cycle
and what we're getting to is as I'm
designing something I'm carrying that
design information through the
production process all the way through
that to that end user and as I'm uh
incorporating the supply chain so
between design and produce and design
and deliver to the End customer I've got
a supply chain and I'm going to create a
digital representation of that supply
chain as well so now I have model based
supply chain
and each of these I can develop a
digital twin of those I can use software
tools I can use you know manufacturing
execution systems I can use uh product
lifestyle management lifecycle
management I could be using
Erp systems to control my production and
my ordering and planning all those
things ideally I connect them while I
use the same set of digital information
and then on top of that here's where we
come in on the simulation side of things
as well as other areas would be we can
use these digital twins to help make
decisions in both strategic and and kind
of real-time basis
and I can go through this digital
transformation as well
I'm gonna hold off on that
um real quick so
this is to me the most fascinating part
of simulation
um the science friend of mine used to
call it I can I can code he called it
the clicking and clacking on the
keyboard
um I can
um you know build statistics in I can do
the validation and things like that
that's the science part of it but the
real part of it is the the art this is
the this is where the experience comes
in so how do I manage a project how do I
build a model that is to the right level
of detail to be able to answer the
questions how do I communicate the
results I can have the best model in the
world but if I can't communicate the
results out of it it's a worthless model
um and then how do I also understand
what the user needs and how do I design
that user experience and one of the keys
is developing that that level of
abstraction
so if we talk about Einstein uh his his
quote a model should be as simple as
possible yet no simpler again this is a
paraphrase of the actual quote at the
bottom uh but that's the that's the the
genius and that's where the art comes in
how do I build a model that's robust
enough yet I don't go into too much
detail because more detail means more
coding more data more verification more
validation more communication everything
there's an expense and overhead on top
of that the more detail I build into it
so what's the right level how do I
design that in
I won't go through an example
um because we're running out of time but
um
[Music]
they're
um
it's easy to build a model that has too
much detail into it and it can also be
easy to build a model that doesn't have
enough detail where I may not account
for certain things that are really
critical of the process that I that I
need to to build into the analysis and
so again this is where that art comes in
and it's also evolutionary as the model
progresses so I start simplistically
ideally and then I build detail in as I
start analyzing the model and
understanding where I might have
differences between the real system and
the modeled system
just some examples um on how I again
might need to build details into a
simulation
but this one I think is real critical so
uh this is a this is uh to the earlier
question this is getting towards
emulation
so
um with plant Sim I probably used a
simulation model to verify that a robot
is the right thing to put into this cell
and I Quantified the impact that the
robot could have I said yes it makes
sense to put it here I can improve my
throughput by adding a robot but then I
can go to the next level and this is a
tool called
process simulate where not only am I
looking at the the nature of kind of the
throughput but I'm actually looking at
the kinematics and the physical
representation of the system to
understand collision avoidance how
actuators are working there's people in
the process so now you can start doing
ergonomic analysis so I'm taking that
process level model and adding more
maturity to it and getting to more
levels of detail
so this is a really great example of
that digital thread where I start with
process model and I you use that
information and now I plug it into a
more robust tool that focuses not only
on on understanding more details about
the process but I can actually create
this emulation of the robot so now I can
test the code that I write to control
the robot I can test it with a virtual
robot so that's where the emulation
comes in and I can do kind of that that
validation and commissioning process
um so I can I can kind of test the the
software against a virtual system and
vice versa
um the other thing I think uh that is uh
coming up that's important is this idea
of hybrid architecture so we talked
about agent-based System Dynamics and
discrete event typically they've been
kind of independent paradigms but now we
have tools that allow us to have for
example a discrete event process running
inside of an agent moving through a
system so now we we're harnessing the
power of these paradigms and creating
these Hybrid models that give us better
capability so for example in healthcare
I might have a process where a patient
is going through the process let's say
in an emergency department yet at the
same time I have an agent that's
controlling their continuous Behavior
things like my temperature is changing
over time and my condition is worsening
as I'm moving through this very discrete
process and so now I can use both of
these approaches to help better model
what's going on within that within that
environment
and lastly the linkage to artificial
intelligence and so we have a whole
community of AI folks that are building
AI algorithms that are discovering that
simulation can be a really powerful tool
to augment what they're doing and so for
example one of the things you can do is
you can build a model of a system to
create the synthetic data and this is a
brain down at the bottom so the person's
developing the algorithm or the brain
needs data to be able to do that and so
rather than going out and trying to
collect data and and
correcting data that comes from a real
system I can start with a model that
generates synthetic data that we know is
is clean good and covers all possible
scenarios and that's what I'm using when
I'm developing the algorithm
then I can actually use that simulation
to train the brain so this is where
there was another talk for uh for pi
data Chicago from the ideologic folks
where they've created a connector uh
between uh Bonsai for example and
pathmind or two environments for
developing AI reinforcement learning
algorithms so now I can use that
simulation to help train the brain
and finally I can actually take that
brain that was trained and insert it
back into the simulation of the
environment and now we can say yes
this this brain is is working well with
this in an environment and if I have a
change in the process I can change the
simulation take that brain put it back
into that into the environment and say
oops this brain needs to be updated I
need to go back through another training
and learning environment and um and
retrain that brain before I put it back
into the system because something in the
system has changed
so so hybrid
um
um models and AI are kind of the the two
latest things that are going on
um and then I'll just show you one last
uh example
um I talked about Healthcare
um this is actually a
uh
this is a a Trauma Center
uh this happens to be
Norwalk Hospital in Norwalk Connecticut
that was done a long time ago uh still a
really
um
a great example of using
simulation in healthcare so in this case
we've probably all been to an emergency
department so I've got
um uh patients coming in both through
ambulance so emergent care and then a
waiting room going through registration
and triage
um I've got Express Care that are open
certain hours of the day I have
behavioral care for folks with
um with Behavioral Care issues that
require special treatment a special
staff I've got ancillary services like
X-ray and so I'm looking at the flow of
individual patients moving through the
system and I have the ability to
interact and say let me change the
number of Staff let me change the number
of doctors that I have let me change the
hours of operation of Express Care for
example and I can understand what the
impact is on the length of stay for for
customers for patients
so just a really good example of of how
simulation can be used to help improve
operations so in this case what it might
be is maybe I'm looking at how many
x-ray Suites do I need for a new
operation so now I can ramp up if I'm
expecting increased volume over the next
couple years
um you know
an x-ray Suite costs you you know one to
two million dollars at least so I want
to make sure and make the right decision
I can do it offline with the simulation
before I actually
actually implement it
so I'm I rushed I apologize for running
late I appreciate your time
um and I see there's a couple questions
um
yes uh here's my contact information if
you have any questions after the
sessions uh just let me know and I
appreciate you sticking with me and um
hope you have a good rest of your
evening
well thank you so much Rainer that was
it's really interesting to learn
um yeah I remember like just learning
about like operations research like
recently so that was cool to see stuff
in simulation
um
okay all right thank you thank you
everybody have a good evening thank you